[Música]
boa noite
até hoje com o meu dá vou falar de um
tema é sobre os grandes desafios
mundiais em nosso papel na sua resolução
por isso falar dos desafios mas
essencialmente as funções
vou falar isso na ótica da experiência é
e conhecimento que adquiri com o gás
porto que tanto gosto e meu trabalho nas
nações unidas mas como engenheiro de
formação é de só falar do nosso problema
que são desenvolver soluções para passos
para soluções para desafios mundiais
importantes duas coisas são muito
importante uma e ser sempre claro e
perceber onde queria buscar a ea segunda
é parte de um contexto real não sabemos
onde queremos chegar
então partimos e não aceitamos isso não
conseguimos desenvolver gol santista
vou começar por aí em maio onde queremos
chegar
desafios mundiais como forma de senso
comum todos nós sabemos dizemos que
queremos um mundo com mais justiça com
mais paz como é o esperado na
distribuição da riqueza e forma também
muito particular dizemos queremos muito
melhor com melhor ambiente de trabalho
com melhor relação entre as pessoas
é claro que cada um de nós achamos que
faltando orientação falta uma linha
orientadora mas existe forma estruturada
em um ano passado as nações unidas com
192 estados-membros subscreveram a
chamada agenda 21 em 2030 em que são
traçados sete objetivos chamados
objetivos do movimento mundial e
sustentava federal todos nós não está
bem estar familiarizados com os
objetivos que nos orientam e 800 nessa
nova agenda ao contrário da anterior é
que são objetivos que não se aplicam só
país em vez de movimento da inflação
pobreza por exemplo
o objetivo explicou todos pedro é
portugal estados unidos qualquer maneira
o pai e mãe que op uma filha qualquer
país que realmente temos consciência que
o desenvolvimento é transversal de
aplicar-se a todos isto é uma notícia
muito importante vou falar portanto a
orientação a uma agenda que nos
comprometemos a objetivos claros
onde queremos chegar aí importante que o
contestam os partidos
o mundo de hoje eu pergunto será que
vivemos no mundo louco esse infeliz em
por vez
não vivemos no mundo com um crescimento
muito grande muito rápido e constante
mudança e muito complexo e eu acho que é
importante aceitar isto
não podemos aceitar o mundo que vivemos
porque conseguimos construir nada eu que
é é um complexo que a única certeza é a
incerteza é muito importante então
grandes feiras às grandes temas
no início meu lado grandes temas vão
começar pelo os mais dramáticos da
pobreza da pobreza é algo que nos fez
perder alguns dos mundos para trazer a
publicar um relatório do banco mundial
por exemplo 1.4 milhões de pessoas em
pobreza extrema e significa que não têm
condições de habitação não têm
alimentação não tem dinheiro não tem
água não tem nada
praticamente um ponto 4 bilhões
a nossa geração milhões de pessoas
passam fome crônica não tenha acesso à
alimentação 1 uma criança entenda aqui
morre 5 ante 115 milhões de crianças na
escola 750 pessoas não têm acesso à água
potável 1.6 bilhão de pessoas não têm
acesso à energia elétrica gerada é
possível isto está dor e todos nós
conhecemos várias realidades mas este é
sem dúvida um dos grandes efeitos
alguns podem surpreender outros grandes
desafios é frágil o gado se ao último
relatório das nações unidas disse que 43
constante questionou em 2030 62% quem
transladado para jogar no seu estádio
gelado uma pessoa que não aguenta o
choque é uma pessoa que até consegue ter
assim está em viver em pobreza mas
porque tem problema econômico tem um
vasto central volta à pobreza 43 pessoas
têm fragilidades
isto é assustador e mais assustador é
que este número é previsto aumentar
isto mostra a insustentabilidade dos
nossos sistemas financeiro e muito ao
grande desafio é segurança só por
exemplo em 2015 105 milhões de pessoas
serão deslocadas por conflitos guerra
mais do que a segunda guerra mundial 65
das pessoas isto é crítico porque não
consegue sim segurança nós também davam
investimento que também não se
desenvolve extenso grande sentimento de
insegurança está a ser constantemente
maior
não fui só surgiu políticas o médio
oriente
tudo nada disto parece muito bom e
presentear é um grande desafio é
ultrapassar desigual pois não se pára ou
acompanhar a grande preocupação que
estão desigual dado eu só dois mundos
contra o terrorismo isto oxfam para
criar recentemente dois números
assustadores um sustento da população
têm a mesma riqueza que os outros 99% 1%
da mesma queda com 59 disseram ainda
mais casos oito pessoas as oito pessoas
mais ricas têm a mesma riqueza que a
outra metade do mundo 3.811 pessoas
sistemas são esses que nós estamos a
desenvolver nos levamos dessa forma
errática com uma conclusão destas
outro tema muito crítica e
sustentabilidade e eu acho que isso daí
os objetivos do desenvolvimento agora
ser chamado se desapegar a agenda em
2030 mas todas ficaram a volta desse nós
realmente estamos num momento em que
precisamos nossos advogados nossos
modelos econômicos educacional ambiente
ajuda humanitária e defendeu que o que
fazemos é sem dúvida
o maior da filha e último desafio
destacou hoje é falou o centroavante
borges também algum preocupa
particularmente mundo
nós vivemos num uma sociedade estamos
numa fase é uma enorme ausência de
referências liderança de vinhais em que
há uma enorme falta de confiança entre
as pessoas entre estados e cuidar
conflitos que levam um crescimento
enorme do extremismo da política é isto
é é é muito eu acho que isso vai ser um
dos grandes nós desafios dos próximos
anos
a maneira como as pessoas confiam cada
vez mais ligados mas cada vez menos
legados
portanto esses são os tais temas que
destacou as grandes desafios para nossa
geração pobreza fragilidade e falta de
segurança desigualdades centralidade e
uma importância ea ausência de valores
de anos assim vou falar agora de
soluções mais importante e ele tem
tamanho meu lado e partilhar com o que
compreende seis pontos fundamentais para
conseguirmos outra passagem está feliz
o primeiro é qual irá e quem é que ganha
com isso em questão
para realmente conseguimos ultrapassar
esta fase é preciso muita qualidade e
vou trazer novas perspectivas diferentes
uma é é qualidade é é convidado e
técnica mas sim técnica que nós nesses
meses antes do desenvolvimento se acham
das entusiastas em resolver tudo isso
tudo a gente está envolvida
os engenheiros os médicos da padaria é
senhora da parceria toda a gente tem
estado envolvida uma vez ligou toda a
gente tem que ter o neném e nós
precisamos do melhor que dom sozinha com
ciúmes
isso é muito importante o segundo
aspecto a qualidade é que a qualidade
não é só técnica é um negócio a
qualidade fazemos as coisas com
qualidade queremos um mundo melhor não é
temos boa técnica que fazemos é esta
manhã a maneira como fazemos as coisas
ao estado e passa por aí
isso é fundamental precisamos número 2
respostas integradas ao extinto
sustentáveis porque dizer com isto temos
que ver os problemas como um todo e não
forma singular
não podemos desenvolver sistemas
econômicos sem pensar em cima da
alimentação é impensável em cima sociais
o apl é um todo e por tanto tempo
precisamos não é a colaboração possamos
dar respostas mais integradas sei quanto
tempo de participar
isto é nós estamos muito abalados e
temos tendência a criticar a dar a
opinião há problema não participar e
isso vai lá se nós não precisarmos nós
temos que participar é importante
contribuir não muda
simplesmente criticar e pouca fé começar
e conquistar com esposa e conversar com
os amigos as coisas estão mal das coisas
não vamos lá e é preciso participar é
preciso participar de forma coerente
isto é o gás porque me ensinou muito e
não posso crer ter um mundo em hora e
segundo zola em casa mas puxaram meu
trabalho e ser um time é ser uma pessoa
difícil de lidar com isso não é ser
coerente
nós temos em todas as coisas que fazemos
aqui compramos na maneira como com menos
na maneira como interagimos com os
amigos da maneira que a gente com
trabalhos da manhã com os decanos das
coisas porque não é é servir é tentar
ser uma opção em part time e isso é uma
coisa boa
outro ponto é ficar no pará que em tudo
que nós fazemos todas as funções nós
desenvolvemos nosso trabalho nem o que
fazemos é importante perceber o que é
que isso vai contribuir realmente está
focado nas pessoas está contribuindo
muito melhor
o último ponto da colaboração não é tão
essencial como é obrigatória e cada vez
o mundo exige mais colaboração
os jogos são cada vez menos e cobras é
fundamental a adição de alguns contos
que eu acho fundamentais para nós
conseguimos ultrapassar esse grande
desafio porque temos à nossa frente um
dos mais importantes e deixei para o fim
que eu penso é mais importante o mais
importante estudo
nós podemos ter consciência dos desafios
é que é importante fazer mas é trabalhar
trabalhar trabalhar
não é não se consegue melhorar o mundo
não se consegue ter um mundo melhor que
saem trabalhar é preciso muito esforço
ea falhar fazer melhor é errar com
pessoas de desculpa e tentar terminar é
fundamental sempre a equipa e
trabalharmos em equipa
as coisas com meu lá muito ao meu lado
nos com raça a e isso não é fácil né não
é nada façam este é um dos meus pontos
finais lidar com tanta coisa é lidar com
tantos desafios a tentar ter uma vida
entrega e encaramos os outros com
sucesso e nos incluir o lixo não é fácil
me ajuda e vou terminar com essa
partilha o que me ajuda a conseguir ter
uma vida de que o livro de conseguir
continuar sempre aplicar macaé é a estes
desafios após a ultrapassagem três
grandes mundiais e contra a empresa
primários outras coisas a primeira os
outros e esse time é um grande sucesso a
sua amiga de sexo eu consigo e por isso
é importante olhar pessoas está próxima
da que o ciclo de nível
eu sei que vou aprender com ela e sei
quanto foi às ruas bares está com outras
pessoas trabalhamos em equipe é
fundamental e isso é pra mim uma das
formas como ajuda na segunda agradecer
quando está quando se tem essa
mentalidade está focado nos outros
problemas de trabalho - não é fácil do
que se pensava ficar essas vezes em
shopping centers e solados agradecer as
graças pinto que temos todas as coisas
boas todos os que mascam acontecendo
aquela pessoa conseguimos levar a melhor
no trabalho para que os momentos em que
somos 1 mil de investimentos orgânicos
ficando embaixo eo ea situação no
trabalho melhora a proteus menos que os
atletas que jogarem mas somos humildes
têm desculpas coisas melhoram a
agradecer essas pequenas coisas vão
acontecer na vida só temos tudo o que
temos em último e pensar em tudo que
faço minhas opções de vida essas opções
e que estranha muita força quando eu
penso
lucas não ser inúteis eu penso que
estamos hoje caminha que nós queremos
um criminoso foi lá onde o menino sei lá
aí quando nós criamos um criminoso ltda
é preciso trabalho esforço e dedicação
mas pois vinha bonito ganhar a loteria
ator está em paz aplicarmos aos outros é
uma vida realmente muito justamente a
sociedade que nos consegue dar força pra
todos
obrigado
[Aplausos]